hello and welcome to this video vini
vidi vici I hope he doesn't really
realize this intention and exam the cats
okay don't know him so we've got the
carers variation hand in the English
might have three is an interesting line
that's not so popular but pretty okay
ships if I if I came here probably just
this check check yeah that looks quite
decent for my test center feels exposed
some pressure on the e4 pawn if he takes
the ship p.m. on d3 I mean it should be
a very decent iqp position yeah what
here I can actually take
yeah maybe just do this and double the
tech you for and b7 the set that this is
an exposed pawn okay so i'm i'm able to
take things now you can even take em b7
i think you don't see why not okay
do the cell rope before this night to d6
now be three so that I have night c4 is
a good retreat route one before now
doesn't do that much yeah potentially
going to d3 but what am I doing here
just canceling I guess maybe look narrow
create rookie one it's got Bishop h5
maybe coming oh yeah this is something
that I should have maybe paid some
attention to might be five to go to d4
would be nice but my nights are somewhat
be five you might have nuptse eight hmm
yeah rookie one Bishop h5 it's a bit of
a problem
might be five he's got Roxy eight this
is a bit a bit bit difficult Roxy 193 I
look scituate don't really see anything
there maybe I can still do this I can
take on v5r remember looking tactics
here now rook c8 should Brooksie 193
Roxy two checks be five hmm great now if
it goes rook c8 now I don't really see a
good move okay yeah okay this is not not
such a big deal I think
yeah it's just a pawn now I'm going to
go look the one and not be five possible
okay it prevents this with bishop by age
five and see any other way to to
organize this yeah maybe this looks it
too and then move the bishop back a
minor piece ending should be a pretty
simple win
a pawn is also quite a week
united five is also a bit in annoyance
for him okay so he just allows me to
take that but I don't know it looks a
bit but difficult this seems easier I
could have taken up seven and should
have taken f7 but he doesn't really have
a great move when he came back to it can
go back to each five but it doesn't
really it doesn't really hurt me time
morning one minute
can just go with the a pony all right so
great five I don't don't have a six
though how to do this and this might be
three I guess check
might be five min even and I have to go
back it's a bit of that sunshine
just have to get to his pawns they all
week check i blundered that one but he
I'm getting the night and not f 3 o'mine
check black resign I didn't didn't
really make life life easy for me in
this game but yeah there was one moment
where he really could have gotten
something I believe check okay so let's
have a look there um check yeah the
opening result i think is quite nice
here white is a little bit better his
center is exposed and I better developed
some ant here okay i'm just taking this
this route and he just dudes upon him
might see six steaks i think this is all
good it's also what the engine likes be
395 maybe he i can improve the engine
wants to go to the one that's not I
didn't consider this route q1 check oh
of course I can take ah ok ok ok ok and
then this is a strong of course ok I
just cancelled it also cannot be bad but
this this is a questionable move I
should probably play a book to d1 then
he has rook c8 now which is a really
annoying move now the idea is something
like a six and my nights are somewhat
overstretched the engine just gives
as a good reply probably am the back
rankus is the thing and this is the move
ok so it wouldn't have been that
terrible but it would have been annoying
this now is very nice yeah i'm just a
pawn up absolutely nothing and its own
it's a pretty yeah it's a pretty good
ending that should win with a good
technical play yeah I think this is all
ok and it's a winning position but yeah
should just take our 7 of course I
didn't I just didn't think at this
moment I just played the move that I had
intended anyway but I don't think I'm
screwing it up it should be a win no
matter what don't know intending light
be three and then King up check it here
ye be going to chat about it I think
it's a win anyway I'm getting to the
points and T I can play more precisely
i'm probably h4 but I mean this is
Janice right it's a winning King and
porn ending um yeah like really got into
trouble out of the opening already not
quite sure it probably has to avoid
Bishop f5 ok the engine wants to take
with this of course yeah this is
playable but white is always better here
Bishop before or just short castle is
better this is a week i QP yeah yeah i
think this line is a little bit better
for what anyway but probably probably
yes to take here and then play this
position the knight c6 i still would
pretty much prefer white but it it's
still fairly solid ok well thanks for
watching